[Música]
sergio massa juró como ministro de
economía en argentina el funcionario
anunció una batería de medidas
destinadas a reducir el déficit fiscal y
estabilizar la economía en medio de una
fuerte inflación y cifras de pobreza al
alza tenemos reportes desde buenos aires
el presidente joe biden firmó una orden
ejecutiva destinada a garantizar el
derecho al aborto la medida ayudaría a
facilitar el desplazamiento de quienes
deseen interrumpir su embarazo así
estados donde este procedimiento esté
permitido
expectativa en colombia por eventuales
negociaciones entre grupos armados y el
gobierno entrante miembros del equipo de
gustavo petro se reunieron con
organizaciones para hablar de posibles
beneficios penales para integrantes de
estos grupos
hola bienvenidos a las noticias de
américa en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz iniciamos en argentina porque
se posesionó el nuevo ministro de
economía sergio massa quien además
tendrá el cargo de superministro ya que
supervisará otras dos oficinas más la
del desarrollo productivo y agricultura
massa anunció cuáles serán las medidas
que tomará para hacer frente a la crisis
económica que vive el país los detalles
de la noticia nos los daba previamente
desde buenos aires nuestro corresponsal
natalio cost hoy a grandes rasgos
primero hizo una mención fuerte a a
ciertos sectores de energía minería
especialmente litio el campo y la
industria del conocimiento y eso de una
idea de una idea de país que puede
querer tener masa y el gobierno en el
mediano y largo plazo pre cosas más
inmediatas por un lado recortar el gasto
público mantenerlo dentro del 2,5 por
ciento del producto interno bruto que es
lo acordado con el fondo monetario
internacional y eso dice que se va a
conseguir con un congelamiento de la
planta del estado para no gastar más en
erogaciones del estado a empleados
públicos que eso es algo que ya había
anunciado la anterior ministra que duró
menos de un mes silvina batakis y
también un mayor recorte a los subsidios
de energía de los ya anunciado que
afectará a más ciudadanos estos
subsidios han representado una enorme
parte del presupuesto nacional en los
últimos años casi décadas y hay que ver
qué impacto puede tener esto sobre la
población pero seguramente será un
recorte muy importante en el gasto
público por otro lado también
incrementar las exportaciones y lograr
que quienes están en el sector
exportador
liquiden que se llama liquidar las
exportaciones para que esos dólares
finalmente entren sobre todo en el
sector agropecuario y dinero entre otros
y de hidrocarburos porque el estado
necesita desesperadamente dólares para
fortalecer las reservas del banco
central
también dijo que se están negociando por
ejemplo con el organismos
internacionales créditos externos para
fortalecer otra vez estas reservas en
argentina que es parte fundamental del
proyecto de sergio massa como ministro
de economía a la vez anunció potenciales
mejoras en jubilaciones acuerdos de
salario en el sector privado y también
busca transformar planes sociales para
que se conviertan más en empleo y la
carga de los premios sociales en el
estado en eeuu el presidente yo bailé en
firmó otra orden ejecutiva para proteger
el derecho al aborto en este nuevo
documento se obliga al departamento de
salud del gobierno a que considere
distintas formas de ampliar la cobertura
para personas gestantes que viajen entre
estados a realizarse este procedimiento
sin embargo se espera que tenga un
impacto limitado ya que los republicanos
están presionando para que se
establezcan leyes que restrinjan el
acceso a los medicamentos y a la
financiación de los servicios de aborto
una nueva estrategia para proteger el
derecho al aborto en eeuu el presidente
joe biden firmó una segunda orden
ejecutiva esta vez destinada a facilitar
que las mujeres viajen entre estados
para acceder al procedimiento
de las mujeres eeuu no deben ser objeto
de debate o perspectiva partidista
confiamos en que las mujeres eeuu tomen
esas decisiones si así lo desean en
consulta con su líder religioso con su
médico con un ser querido pero
entendemos perfectamente que el gobierno
no debería tomar esa decisión por ellas
desde la decisión de la corte suprema de
eeuu para anular roe versus wade la casa
blanca se ha visto limitada en lo que
podría hacer para reaccionar sin la
acción del congreso al igual que la
primera orden ejecutiva firmada en julio
la última orden no detalla cuándo ni
cómo se protegerá en el aborto y los
derechos reproductivos
las acciones de bailén se producen un
día después de que los votantes de
kansas rechazarán eliminar el derecho al
aborto de la constitución del estado el
voto de kansas es el primero de muchos
que piden los votantes para opinar sobre
el asunto
la campaña de boudou podría dar un
impulso a los estados que consideren
propuestas electorales para cambiar la
constitución incluye dos que en toki
california vermont y posiblemente
michigan
los demócratas esperan que el tema del
derecho al aborto pueda ayudar a llevar
a los votantes a las urnas en las
elecciones intermedias de noviembre
en colombia en los días previos a la
posesión del 7 de agosto del presidente
electo gustavo petro y la vicepresidenta
electa francia márquez su futuro
gobierno sigue avanzando en la
consecución de la paz total los
principales grupos armados ilegales ya
dicen estar abiertos a negociaciones
luís muñoz nos trae más detalles
colombia camino a la paz total en una
reunión de miembros del futuro gobierno
con organizaciones se habló de una
estrategia de acogimiento y beneficios
penales para los grupos criminales en
lugar de sometimiento eso sí desde la
justicia
es impresentable
ante los propios colombianos el pensar
que puede hacerse proceso de paz e
impunidad el clan del golfo o
autodefensas gaitanistas de colombia
podría tener beneficios judiciales se
aporta de las acciones y rutas de
narcotráfico esto cuando en las últimas
semanas han llevado a cabo un plan de
asesinatos de policías denominado plan
pistola matando a al menos 36
uniformados una forma de mostrar control
territorial y unidad de cara a la
negociación
otra posibilidad de paz conocida el
miércoles ha sido con las disidencias de
las farc pese al desarme de la que fuera
la guerrilla más grande de américa
latina en 2016 antiguos mandos
abandonaron el proceso y se
reorganizaron ahora se abren a una
segunda oportunidad
como un acuerdo queremos un clima
propicio
pero de la negociación que más se ha
hablado en las últimas semanas es con la
guerrilla de ln retomando las
conversaciones iniciadas en la habana
durante el gobierno de juan manuel
santos y rotas en el de iván duque así
ha estado tuiteando su comandante alias
antonio garcía importante que haya
expectativas por la paz en colombia es
la paz el principal objetivo del
gobierno de gustavo petro y francia-
márquez quienes tomarán posesión el 7 de
agosto
[Aplausos]
en bolivia siguen las protestas de
cultivadores de coca en contra de lo que
consideran es un nuevo mercado ilegal de
este producto en la paz y exigen que se
ha cerrado las manifestaciones derivaron
nuevamente en enfrentamientos con la
policía que lanzó gases lacrimógenos e
incluso se presentaron detonaciones de
dinamita que provocaron el cierre de
negocios cercanos los detalles nos los
daban previamente nuestra corresponsal
en la paz mery vaca los cocaleros de los
yungas agrupados en adepcoca y la
policía nacional de bolivia han
protagonizado una tercera jornada
consecutiva de enfrentamientos en la
ciudad de la paz en esta ocasión la
policía ha utilizado gases lacrimógenos
para repeler a los cocaleros además de
balines de goma por su parte los
productores de coca han hecho uso de
petardos pero también han hecho reventar
dinamita en el barrio de villa fátima
donde se ha producido la refriega de
esta jornada debo comentarles además que
los vecinos de este barrio están muy
molestos y hasta desesperados por esta
situación porque estar mirando
diariamente gases lacrimógenos y
escuchando las detonaciones de dinamita
por eso han pedido al gobierno de luis
arce que resuelva de una vez el
conflicto que existe entre los cocaleros
de adepcoca y la dirigencia denominada
paralela debo decirles que este barrio
es muy populoso con alta concentración
humana y también de muchos negocios
durante esta jornada el gobierno de luis
arce ha dicho que va a convocar a los
dos sectores en pugna es decir al sector
dirigido por freddy machicado dea de
coca y al sector encabezado por arnold
al danés a quien se le acusa de ser
miembro del partido de gobierno para que
se sienten en una mesa de negociaciones
y de una vez puedan resolver el
conflicto hay que recordar que en
bolivia la venta de coca tradicional es
legal y para eso según la ley existen
solamente dos mercados en todo el país
uno está ubicado en la paz y el otro en
cochabamba por eso los cocaleros de
adepcoca están molestos porque se ha
abierto un nuevo mercado también y la
paz y han decidido como hasta lograr su
cierre y finalizamos con información
deportiva porque hubo jornada con muchos
goles en la copa libertadores en el
duelo de argentinos vélez sarfield
venció 3 a 2 a talleres de córdoba
mientras que en el juego de equipos
brasileños atlético mineiro y palmeiras
empataron 2 a 2
de esta manera despedimos este
informativo en france 24 gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]